he called me and he told me there was a  fire it was a steam car that just his  name is made by gas and it got sprayed  in what has been described as a quote  serious medical emergency Jay sustained  a massive burn to his face after one of  his cars erupted into flames inside his  La garage Jay released a statement  saying quote I am okay just need a week  or two to get back on my feet today ET  spoke with Jay's mechanic George Swift  foreign Jay is being hospitalized at the  Grossman burn center that is the same  facility that treated Anne Heche after  her fatal car fire it's just practicing  a little bit here in the Leno garage  back in 1987 E.T was with Jay inside his  then home garage the then 37 year old  comic told us why his vehicle collection  is so important it's just relaxing you  know I'd be sitting down and actually  working on my career  which is real boring